قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه شنت امس هجوما واسع النطاق على
خمسه قطاعات في اتجاه جنوب دنيا واضافت
الوزاره ان قوات احبطت الهجوم وقتلت 250
جنديا اوكرانيا اضافه الى تدمير 16 دبابه
وثلاث مركبات نقل مشات و 21 عربه مصفحه
واضاف المتحدث باسم الوزاره 6 كتائب اليه
وكاتبتي دبابات اوكرانيه شاركت في الهجوم
الاوكراني وقالت الوزاره ان رئيس هيئه
الاركان العامه الروسيه بليري برسم اوف
كان في المنطقه التي وقع فيها الهجوم
الاوكراني
سدره في صباح يوم الرابع من يونيو سنه
القوات الاوكرانيه هجوما واسع النطاق في
اتجاه جنوبسك من خلال ادخال الويه
ميكانيكيه وبدعم من الوحدات العسكريه
الاخرى شاركت ست كتائب اليه اضافه الى
كتيبتاي الدبابات في الهجوم كان الهجوم
يهدف الى اختراق دفاعاتنا الا ان العدو
فشل في مهامه نتيجه الاعمال الماهره
والمختصه لمجموعه الشرق بلغت خسائر القوات
الاوكرانيه اكثر من 250 جنديا وسته عشره
دبابه وثلاثه مركبات قتال مشاه اضافه الى
احدى وعشرين مركبه قتال
في المقابل نشرت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
مقطع فيديو يظهر عناصر من القوات
الاوكرانيه تشير باشاره الصمت معنونه
المقطع بالقول ان الخطط تحتاج الى الصمت
وانه لن يكون هناك اعلان للبدء وقد اظهر
الفيديو مجموعه من الاختصاصات العسكريه
القتاليه والاليات والمدرعات بما فيها
طائرات الحربيه وهي في حاله فعاليه قتاليه
وكانت وسائل اعلام اوكرانيه قد نشرت فيديو
قالت انه الاختراق بث قنوات روسيه بشبه
جزيره القرن وبثعلان وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه بشان التزام الصمت